- Dude, this is
So do you remember he said
he's got a bunch of stuff?
I know I've been
waiting for this one.
Ryan and I are
taking another trip
over to our good friend, Dean
Pickles, for some inspiration.
The whole family knows
how to do cars up right.
I can't wait to see what
they've got going on now.
Yeah, dude.
That is your welcoming
car right there.
Dude, already old
school Lincoln Mark 3.
And, dude, what is this?
Whoa.
I don't know what that is.
I'm telling you right now,
if someone said, what is it?
My first answer
is, I don't know.
My second answer
is, maybe a Citroen?
Look at the doors.
Reverse suicide and standing.
- They open this way?
They open this way.
I've never seen that before.
That's too cool.
Look at this, man.
Oh, this if four wheel drive.
There's no hump.
No hump in the floor.
It is, yeah.
What's up, fellas?
I'm going to get--
what's happening, my man?
- It's good.
Good to see you, man.
- How are you, man?
Thank you for
having us out here.
Hey, Ryan.
How you been?
Appreciate it, man.
Bro, I've got to
ask, what is it?
That's a '47 Citroen.
He shoots, he scores.
You've got to be kidding me.
French cars, really?
You know those too.
Oui.
[laughter]
The Citroen Company began by
building armaments for France
during World War I but
quickly switched over
to cars in the post-war era.
They soon became known for the
revolutionary lightweight cars
with unitary body, no separate
frame, and front wheel drive,
or as the French called
it, traction avant.
During the Second
World War, Citroen
suffered extreme losses.
The factory was bombed twice.
And sales came to
a screeching halt.
But the company came
back stronger than ever.
And by 1947, it was back to
pre-war production levels.
A Citroen.
OK.
- Yeah.
That's what I'm trying
to wrap my mind around.
Exactly.
Where, when, what, and why?
Just because I'm like you.
I like unique, different
things that you can't find.
And you don't ever see
these in the states.
How long have you had it?
About a year now.
From where?
It came out Arizona.
And the gentleman
that I bought it from
had it shipped from
overseas to here.
Wow.
So he had it when it was nice?
- Yes.
- Like a running, driving car.
Yeah, he had it
when it was nice.
Yeah.
Dean, let me
ask you this, bro,
what in the world
are you planning
on doing with a '47 Citroen?
It's on the back burner.
It's on--
[laughter]
Impulse buy.
I've got some of those too.
- I know how that works.
- You've got a few of those.
I've got a few of those.
I've got about 5 more
Mustangs to do first.
- All right.
- Yeah.
More Mustangs?
Wow.
Yeah, more Mustangs.
Well, let's take a look.
Let's see what you're
hiding back here.
Just a little
bit of everything.
Just got like a
little overflow here.
What are you hiding in there?
This is a '72 Mach 1 Mustang.
Oh, man, what a beautiful car.
Dean's collection is
always a treat, man.
And today has been no exception.
But I can't wait to find out
more about this Mach One.
I've got to tell you this
thing is just stunning.
Thanks, Danny.
You guys always
do beautiful work.
And I love how the backs of
these things just lay out.
The window is this
being big, right?
Yeah.
But you only see
that much out of it.
Yeah.
It's like a mail
slot that's this big.
What are you going to put in
this for drive train, bro?
It's got the 351 Cleveland
that's going in it.
But you know we need
to always go faster.
What did you do?
- Stroked it out to a 408.
- Really?
408?
Yeah, ti's got the--
Oh, this is her laying here.
This is it right here.
She's already been dinoed.
She dinoed out at
520 horse power.
Ooh.
Yes.
This thing's going to rock.
Yeah, it's going to fly.
What else do you got here?
We've got a 1928 Model A Ford.
It's beautiful.
The Model A was Henry Ford's
follow up to his original Model
T. With its 40
horsepower engine,
this baby could push a top
speed of 65 miles per hour.
Slow by today's
standards, but that's
nearly double the speed of the
Model T. The sportier Model A's
initially sold great.
But by 1932, its last
year of production, sales
had plummeted due to the
ongoing Great Depression.
- This one here is all original.
- It's all stock?
The original owner.
What?
He was still alive.
So you are the second
owner of this car?
Yeah.
Bro, that's as
rare as it gets.
Stuff like that
doesn't happen.
What kind of
shape was it in when
you got it from this gentleman?
Just like this.
You're kidding me?
Yes.
Most of these things are
either turned into hot rods
or cut up, or they're
garbage by now.
So to see one pure and original
like this, this is gorgeous.
Look at this
little tiny engine.
Yeah, it ain't like what
you guys are used to seeing.
[laughter]
They make sewing
machine bigger than that.
Little four cylinder.
Oh, Dean, I love it.
What a neat car.
- Yeah, it is.
Every time we get to see you.
Bro, you inspire us, man.
- Thanks, Danny.
Thank you for letting
us see this stuff.
I can't wait to see this
Mustang when it's done.